صباح الخير اا احنا هنا معانا اا يعني بجد
بنت ب 100 راجل همم سهيله همم ازيك يا
سهيله هي بنت عملت الورشه بتاعتها والمعرض
بتاعها ده اللي بتعمل فيه منتجات معات
تدويره هي بقى تكلمنا اكثر تعملي ايه يا
سهى صباح النور ازاي حضرتك اول حاجه انا
بعمل منتجات جلديه وباستغل كل الحاجات
قعدت التدوير اللي انا باستخدمها في
المجال بتاعي همم سواء كانت حاجات معلقات
او اضاءه او اي حاجه او حاجه همم كوحده
نعرض عليها الحاجه تمام زي مثلا ترابيزه
بعيد تدويرها ثاني تكون اعملها باف للجلوس
همم زي ظهر ال- ال- ال-
الكرسي الخشب القديم بتاع زمان لو هو مرمي
في الشارع ممكن اخذه واعمله كم وحاجات
معلقات منها بعد دهانوا بعد همم
وحدات معلقه وكده يعني بتاخذي حاجات قديمه
انت هتفرجيني بقى كده دلوقت تفرجيني اه
تمام
همم ده مثلا ده ظهر كرسي تمام فانا اخذته
عملته معلقه كده عشان الوحده الرف ليا
تمام ده مثلا بف انا عملته وديتي ترابيزه
فانا جبت سفنج وجبت قماش
وقمت عاملاه عشان يبقى وحده عرض او او
مكان الجلوس ده مثلا
ده اللي هو همم منخل زي ما بيقولوا ده
المنخول اللي انا اه اثناء تجهيزي المكان
بتاعي قدام ننخل به الرمله وكده فخلاص ما
بقاش له استخدام معي فقمت شايله منه السلك
وقمت عاملاه بالوحده دي عملت وحده اضاءه
انت اللي بتجيبي الحاجات القديمه دي بقى
ازاي ناس بتديها لك ولا انت بتدور عليها
همم ساعات وانا ماشيه بالعجله او قبليه
كده بالاقي حاجه لها لازمه ينفع تنفعني
همم باجيبها بالاقي ليه نظره فيها ان هي
ممكن تتعمل منها حاجه تمام وخصوصا لما
تكون حاجات قديمه الحاجه عريقه يعني هي
متينه بس ما ملك تمام
بالنسبه لي مفيد جدا بيوفر عليها كل حاجه
سهيله انت المكان ده وضبتيه بيدك مش كده
ما اخذتيش اي قرود اي سلفه انت عملتي بيدك
كل حاجه وبفلوسك صح اه تمام انا طبعا انا
اخذت المكان انا وضبت حاجه من شغلي كنت
جاي هنا على لمبه واحده بس تمام
فابتديت ان انا اطلع الكهرباء المحروقه من
الحيطه
واكسر الحيطان عشان ادهنها وبعدين عملت
ورق حائط انت بايدك مفيش عمال لا لا انا
كنت باجيب عامل الاول عشان يكسر لي فلقيت
ان هو مش بيعمل حاجه صح وبي الحاجات كلها
بقيت اطلعها بيدي من الحيطه فابتديت انا
اضيف الشاكوش وجبت الادوات الكوريك
والحاجات دي
وكيشه ثقيله تمام عشان اكسر بها همم وبعد
المرحله اللي بعدها جبت رمل وقعدت يعني
التاسيس كله انت بنفسك همم سهيله انت همم
يعني انت تخصصك ايه اصلا لا انا تجاره
اداره اعمال مش شغلي خالص بس همم انا كنت
حابه الامر دوت
فانا ابتديت انا اعمل الحاجه اللي انا
بحبها واللي انا من زمان وانا بعيد تدوير
الحاجه وبردك انا اللي عامله الشبهات دي
تمام انا اللي رسمه ديزاين بتاعها وجبت
الخشب ورحت المغلق بتاع الخشب حددت له
يقطع ازاي وانا اللي جمعتها ومسمتها كله
هاند بايد هو الديزاين بتاعها اسمه سهيله
هاند ميد كله هاند ميديا سهل كثير
بتاعها تمام شكرا عايزه اشكر سهيله جدا
سهيله انت نموذج هايل فتاه مكافحه همم
شكرا لكم صباح الخير عليكم شكرا